do you remember when Obama's daughter
got caught smoking weed at 13 years old
yes do you remember what Obama said what
Obama said you know
I the struggles of being a teenager I
remember I went through it myself as
well you know as a family we love her
and we're going to get through this and
papa you know what we said as an
audience what do we say okay okay cool
you're not you know what cool cool moved
on yeah when Bill Clinton I did not have
you know yeah relations with that woman
yeah Miss Lewinsky yeah they're quoting
Chappelle right anyway so and then what
happened you're like dude no it's fine
yeah we don't say our son should be like
you when they grow up although he
inspired a lot of people well half the
country didn't care the other half
really really cared about the BJ I don't
care about McDougall I don't care about
uh
stormy I don't care about any of that
stuff listen if if you and by the way
the whole role model situation yeah
there's an element of President being a
role model I totally agree there's an
element of the governor's being a role
model I get that but I want to make sure
you got good policies to get good
results this is why when people say how
can you with Trump I like his policies
that's that's all it is I like his
policies his policies were very
effective for business it was a lot less
peace it was a lot more peaceful until
kova took place so even if you go back
to Reagan
imagine you have a son and you name your
son after you okay and you name him
Ronald Reagan and guess what the kid you
named after you hates your policies do
you know that story do you know Ronald
Reagan Jr completely disagrees with his
father you know what did media do he's
an atheist now he's he's you know but
but guess what guess what American
people said look everybody has issues
with their kids sometimes you have it
sometimes some kids want to do this hey
no problem we understand it hey why
aren't you wanting to cover the story
here but Pat can I post a uh maybe an
opposing view there is a difference
between the actual man the president and
what they do like you brought up
McDougall Trump Stormy Daniels Trump
Clinton Monica Lewinsky Right Reagan
he's allegedly had affairs on Nancy
versus the kids like you brought up one
of the Obama daughters smoking weed or
even hunt or smoking crack or even stuff
that
Eric Trump allegedly did what have you
there is a difference between the
president and what they do and their
kids can't control what the kids do I
don't condone some of the stuff that
Hunter's done for sure it's not a good
look for the country but it's not like
it's the president doing those things if
I was a guy who would make short clips I
would take what you just said and I
would take what you said A week before
about guns that if something kid does
the parents should be held accountable
and that contradicts itself well if you
murder somebody what are you talking
about you're doing stuff to 12 year old
girls I mean these are minors well some
people would say this is worse than
murder I mean 12 year old girls you
haven't seen what 4chan brought up
yesterday with links on this guy doesn't
follow Fortune no no I don't either I
don't I don't even know who 4chan was
until yesterday but 4chan they came out
and they said the uh you know they found
Links of this guy visiting watching porn
with 12 year old girl okay so anyways
that concerns no doubt Hunter Biden's a
freaking creep yeah
but to your argument to your point that
you made just a week ago it is you're I
didn't say my point this is your point
to your point you said if the sun does
it parents needs to be held around I
still stand by that comment if you're
gonna if your kid is gonna go out there
and we're talking about uh the latest
thing and uh where was that the like
there's so many people there's any
goddamn Maps
but if you're gonna go ahead and take
seven people's lives yeah yeah we're
gonna hold your family accountable so
okay so I'm sticking with that let me
ask you a question it's not that's
different from what the president don't
tell that story what no no you don't get
look we all contradict that's murder
that's something that you're taking
people's lives
whether your kid does drugs or not
that's a difference I don't say drugs I
didn't say drugs murder is murder
totally get it what about a 50 year old
man having sex with a minor
should go to jail that's it
I don't know should there be an
accountability for the father
no but there should be accountability
for the person that killed uh yes but by
the way mass murder has different uh not
mass murder have a murder period how
about murder period
no I'm talking about mass murder of
innocent people that should we're
conflating two different things we're
you're I see what you're saying here you
do have a point yeah you're basically
saying Adam you're kind of contradictory
accountability should be held to the
parents all I'm saying I'm talking about
accountability for Mass emerging but
we're talking about gun violence so it's
kind of like some please don't kill more
than one person because if you kill two
I'm also going to jail just kill one
something needs to be done I get that
all I'm saying is like look sometimes
I'll give ideas okay and I'll go in a
room and I'll say I want you to be
Devil's Advocate argue my arguments just
debate me right because I want to know
if I have any leaks in my argument okay
you said that last week people thought
about it created a bunch of attention oh
you know what parents should be held
accountable that's the case but okay
that comes a week later if this is true
should he be held accountable for what
his son did he's not a child who's not a
child Hunter's not a child he's not a
child yeah he's not living at home and
then but these people are also not
children that he was talking about last
week that are doing passion they're also
not 13 14 years old they're also grown
men and men that are that are doing this
arguably grown 17 18 19 20. I think I
think the life experience that takes
place in the 30 years age difference
between the recent shooter and and
Hunter I I I agree I I think that
there's certain accountability
especially if the raising of that child
is so close to that period of time I I
don't think I think Hunter's been Joe's
Bag Man for the past 25 years so I don't
think there's been any upbringing or
raising coming from Joe I think it's a
it's a power Dynamic map Joe's the boss
and Hunter is the worker I think I think
you guys completely missed my point I'm
on the same page with that my history
his point last week was parents should
be held accountable for what the kid
does with mass shooting that's his point
last week that's what I'm saying for me
what Hunter did is what Hunter did I
just said what what Obama's kids do is
what Obama's could do it Ronald Reagan
you do what you got to do you know the
the minor stuff I'm I'm that's a that's
a little that's very sensitive to
appearance and all that stuff that you
go through but to him if he did do what
he did
and all these things that are coming out
with his involvement with politics with
zelinski with Ukraine why you're so
protect every it's a little bit weird
when you're very very protective of
somebody all of a sudden you ever had a
situation where something happened and
one of the guys is all of a sudden
overly protective of a girl you're like
hey bro that's a little um
[Music]
dude you've never talked like that
before how did you all of a sudden
become so protective of Ukraine like did
you do you have some lineage did you do
ancestry.com and they said you're 62
Ukrainian and you're like I don't know
what happened there that you're so so
that's the part where there's a little
bit of speculation and I would like the
professional investigative journalists
to go out there and do some
investigative journalism so I I just
don't think anything is going to happen
like and I was thinking about this if
Trump wins this next president yeah even
if they do an investigation
Joel will be out of he won't be the
president anymore these people just
nothing happens nothing ever happens to
these people the pro we have the proof
you know it he he's seen a lot we're
seeing like he's smoking crack uh every
every day he just there's another video
where he's weighing like 20 grams of of
crack cocaine with the girl and but
nothing's gonna happen let's be frank
about this this isn't just any
father-son Duo right so Hunter Biden is
smoking a lot of crack right and he just
wait out as Vinnie said 20 grams of
crack Joe Biden wrote the original
legislation with mandatory sentencing
laws for crack cocaine saying if you had
five grams you've got five years
mandatory no probation off at him okay
secondly Hunter Biden has lied on a
federal gun form right he purchased a
weapon and lied on the gun form and then
threw the weapon in the dumpster it's
like I I do think there is a point to
where Joe Biden has to be held
accountable for some of this I I don't I
don't disagree with that part I agree
with that part there needs to be
accountability here but regardless there
needs to be investigative journalism so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]